hello Roy how are you going on me and
good seat you just tranquilized him he
just wakes up in space in a Tesla and
he's cold yeah what the [ __ ] are you a
comic book movie fan we're just talking
about the new venom do you give a [ __ ] a
comic book boys like that you know
web-shooters oh you you geeked out over
you can care less I can't get into it
though I want to care about it because
it's one of those things where it's like
it's it's like a the whole fantasy genre
is silly to me like I'm like this isn't
real life this No did you like my wife
my mum my wife hates a sci-fi or fantasy
genre unless there you know there's a
love story we have there's a love story
and everybody can have of course I think
they put them in cinema yeah I think
they put them in sometimes because they
want a couple to go or somebody oh yeah
Marvel films I just don't give a [ __ ]
about them I think they want a couple to
go with them and they have to put some
kind of an angle in there to make it
interesting I think so it's not just a
guys movie yeah true but I mean I mean
they're a lot better than what they used
to be I mean I had my uh I just had my
little kid to watch Superman the first
time he's like dude I love that one DUSU
per man's lifting up the car the first
super in first one like with 82 or 70s I
think I want to at least 79 or 80 the
first Superman with Christopher Reeve
and Margot Kidder yeah yeah I think so
no they think that you need to like CGI
everything and make it wow this
generation just doesn't take it
seriously but if you show a little kid
like movies from the 80s they're like
yeah it's [ __ ] awesome I just showed
my kids the golden child the other day
mildly more aggressive than I remember
to be so I get parent of the week for
that one percent is that one of those
things where you watch it like 15 years
later 20 years later yeah this was kind
of fun and you're like oh my god this is
not for a child to watch 100 percent
look in the middle I was like I kept
waiting for like the really dope parts
to pull out me like a little underneath
the leaf and all that stuff I'm like
that I want the knife and all that and
it was like blood porridge and like
death and murder and mayhem and and
triple six and I was like sorry kids
let's change that I don't remember the
movie but I guess you're right later
instead I mean movies now like they used
to get away with so much more in term
of like just violence and things like
that and film oh hell I think about now
like remember Richard Pryor like the toy
the toy right way in hell the toy would
fly nowadays I know Oh chance no it
wasn't even that great a movie I mean
you Cleese in and prior to the funniest
people ever and they just the movie was
not it didn't it didn't cut it but it
was still like push the envelope so hard
remember and then what was the one with
Gene Wilder and Richard Pryor stir crazy
the oh I told you interrupted you how
about I want to talk to for a long time
I thought that y'all's interview with
Artie Lange was absolutely spectacular
the most recent one we go I don't know
if his most recent one were y'all talk
about his addictions we that when he had
his shirt off this one probably shirt
off yeah yeah yeah I thought it was
incredible I thought the insight that
y'all were providing in there and I like
when you got sober how you did it why
you did it because you got sober young
very very onion yeah and it was it was a
real trip to hear that like the insight
that you guys both had and talk about
like the the darkness that is santim
comedy right but also like that the
intellect oh yeah I didn't really
necessarily touch on that but like to
intellect that that you have to have to
find the the idiosyncrasies and the
ironies of everyday life that nobody
picks up on that you guys can like
trigger on and make jokes about to kind
of point out and that's the point of
stand-up isn't it like to point out that
the oddities that go on in life I think
you tried you you want to I mean
sometimes it works sometimes it doesn't
yeah a lot of times I try to point
something out and people just like shut
up and there's other times where you're
not trying to point something out and
people laugh I guess it depends on what
you trying to do in a moment it's
probably it's always the worst I can
stand up when people try to point
something out but they do it literally
like you know you've not succeeded what
you're supposed to like through a joke
be able to make people like them but
when you're going like so what I'm
saying is and you have to like break it
down a second oh yeah we got it stupid
would be quiet are you guys now you guys
you guys are fighting one to one do you
fight by the way this Friday this Friday
night that's right it's in Mohegan Sun
know we're up in Connecticut and you're
going out and I've been of you fighters
are doing press together before or do
you guys have an issue with it is it
weird what knowing that you have to
fight or are you guys friendly off when
you're not fighting
no we're good you are good yeah we're
cool we tax them talk to each other on a
regular basis even while you're training
to fight each other
so while you're training to fight each
other you're still texting and if we if
we do is any reason for us I'm sure we
would write a joke yeah oh you're
serious
I just want to what the psychology we
trained last week together but it's when
guys do press together I'm always
wondering if it gets tense like the week
of the fight or if it's just it doesn't
matter it well you know it does
sometimes but not like in this cyber
type of situation but like if I didn't
like Matt and Matt didn't like me then
we had some problems then definitely
some tenseness but usually it doesn't
really happen that much in our sport
unless you really didn't like most of
time people in our sport are pretty cool
like if you're a dick you're a dick and
it's gonna it's gonna come out in the
wash it's already been that way you're
fighting or not you're a dick those are
pretty cool anyways well you remember
Joe and Jack or me I couldn't be in the
room together that got ugly where they
were like when they were talking to each
other I don't know how much pre-plan
that was just Jones is Pro mowing but
they would just talk to each other off
air on mic and it got picked up and
those guys I would not want to interview
in the same room because what do you do
if to [ __ ] you know to heavyweights
or to light heavyweights or going and
John such as a casual smartass he's
gonna say something
that's a good spin and just irritate for
sure but there's no thing to sit back
and watch I wouldn't interfere if you
guys start going at it you're [ __ ]
until when he is dead I'm not jumping at
it when when when when I was out in
Florida we had Tyrone Spong he's one of
the best kick boxers in the world and
Alistair Overeem we're in the same camp
and they would spar each other and they
would spar another when nobody else was
around in the gym and like all of us
would just like sit around the corner
like you know like just watch it's like
like way like peeking around the corner
to see how they were getting down I mean
it was incredible I was there's no one
around because they knew was gonna draw
a massive crowd and really uh and and
Tyrone Spong was just a beast at that
moment so he was he was he was putting
the screws on him did you see him get
knocked out by and god that's one of the
worst knockouts I've ever seen he's
literally when stiff before I've ever
seen anybody goes stiff before they hit
the ground you see him get knocked out I
think the whole world I think that
without even don't even have internet
probably either heard it or felt it I've
done that reference on stage a couple of
times at half the audience laughs half
the audience will laugh at an ovary
in Ghana reference which is pretty
shocking that anybody gets it yeah
that's a lot yeah but more people than
you'd expect great and you both played
team sports - you played rugby and you
played obviously professional football
what what made you get a football
well football got done with me yeah yeah
football got down with me in week six of
2005 and then my son was born that
following week so then I told theis my
theis to the Viking terrible timing
terrible I told tights like look if
y'all don't bring me back for at least
two weeks or in the active season I'm
gonna retire because I can't have
somebody else control my paycheck with a
kid so they didn't and then you know
it's a pipe dream right like what
they'll do and it says it's it's what
they do with everybody is that if you're
not vested as soon as the season's over
they're like hey man we're gonna sign
you we tried to sign you a couple times
we just couldn't do it so they'll want
you to sign you as soon as the season's
over so that way you're on for another
eight months nine months in hopes that
you're gonna make the team again so you
can just it's a perpetual pipe dream
so if you don't ever give yourself a
stop line you'll you'll you'll never
come to it unless you get forced into it
well how are you gonna make money after
that like if you if you think okay I
might get Rhys I need like just let me
know what what were you doing for Olivia
um well I started I had to go to
corporate America like III took a job
designing and selling employee benefit
packages for corporations and that's
kind of what I had to do because I
didn't like I didn't know where my life
was going to go and I didn't have many
transferable skills you get you get
depressed like when you're sitting there
like you're in like your interests in an
office you're in cubicle or whatever and
you're just thinking about like I used
to play in front of like a stadium full
of people and this is what I did
actually
how could I be here the anonymity never
bothered me at all like the spot of like
slapping things that nobody cares about
and trading pennies and driving 4000
miles a month of windshield time it's
just like that [ __ ] like hurt my soul
and like seeing my body go from like
from something of a trained body to it
just a doughnut chewing on Telugu who
drops off doughnuts and coffee you know
it's just that really hurt my feelings
am I feeling so I'm such a millennial
really that really true yeah for sure
and that's what kind of got me in the
gig but also I started this portion
attrition company up
when I got down in the NFL because I
didn't know what to take I didn't know
what was what would I would get popped
for what was like what sugars are better
for you versus this and that and so I
started doing my own research and I was
like you know what I don't see anything
else on the market that has what I that
has what I'm looking for so I made my
own product and then we are in 21
divisional and universities on the trial
basis and that's what got me into MMA
and that's what that's what only reason
why I went on The Ultimate Fighter was
just to propagate my company just to do
product placement on the TV show so that
afterwards I could have some exposure
that was would cost me a gazillion
dollars to get and that's what I reason
why one of those I'm a fighter I never
wanted to be a fighter and then I fought
Marcus and I fought Kimbo and then
everything changed and how about you
what did you do before you fly I mean
besides playing Ryan II played rugby
yeah I did that professionally you did
is they do all right they do if you go
down you know in Australia no for me I
was rugby was a place to give me a good
fashioned where I could drink right
after practice okay you like do you like
the tip a few back there do you miss
team sport at all or no the one thing
the reason why I had always had a
problem with team sports like I was
really good with baseball like I
could've probably played a professional
baseball and just politics you know I
just want I'm one of those guys that
just really sucks with politics you mean
the politics of like any group politics
isn't like all the coaches you know son
has to get started because we're the
alumni you know some sub dad paid and
paid a little a couple more bucks than
the other father so he gets to start
first or like I'm all about winning did
you run into that at all though all the
time that's a reason why I switched from
team sports to an individual sport he
was just talking before like this
morning they totally different we're
talking about the Sex in the City
[ __ ] thing and like how Kim Cattrall
and Saturday party hate each other and
it just came out and Instagram was just
really really who was your guys favorite
I was really surprised that Kim Cattrall
did that and that really like it just
threw her she threw herself under the
bus like all Sarah Jessica Parker looks
like the great chick now like all she
was trying to do was look into a friend
in blah blah blah and be the bigger
person and then Ken Coachella does that
and that was the question we were asking
each other have you ever been that mad
at somebody that like a family member of
yours could die no good saw a person
reaches out to you a person reaches out
to you and goes like oh my condolences
and you're still like no man [ __ ] you
I can't imagine have you been that mad
at anybody and misdirected rage yeah I
don't know I don't get it there must've
been some real sideways [ __ ] on that and
that yes and that's that behind the
scenes that kind of politicking or a
little little groups get formed and all
of a sudden everybody hates each other's
guts so I guess that's what the problem
with you and doing the teams for us ya
know it I could definitely see it you
know like someone got pissed off really
bad really bad like I mean if you hold
that type of grudge you know afterwards
it's like you you killed my family or
you ate my you know my first young well
you a guy who would fight a lot as a
person when you were not I mean not
professionally a guy who would throw it
out and quickly in real life no I would
seem very even-tempered no I'm the I'm
the first guy for a verbal combat like
you know like I'm the first one to try
to talk out of a fight you know like
like the very first thing like if
someone ever tries to approach you for a
fight I'm like oh really how much money
you have and then that doesn't stop the
fight there then you put the mouthpiece
in you're like okay you know like you
just keep on like anyway to a get from
not going into the fight versus where
everybody else is so hot oh you'll he'll
try to bet the money on the fight that
is the same thing actually that's funny
fight somebody let's gamble on this how
much money got in your pocket like well
I fight for more than that so go ask
your friends if you can give you come up
with 20 G's in the next hour let's talk
it's not worth my time you paid a lot
more than that is that what your fear is
like that something's gonna happen and
you're just gonna wind up in court
you fight some guy in the subway you're
gonna want to get into it for like we're
gonna kill somebody
oh you've what you worry more about that
for sure yeah if you've got somebody up
and they drop to the ground right and
their head hits the ground and they die
or have seizures or whatever else if I
was sitting next to a guy that I was
gonna fight later in the week I would
hate for that to be his response yeah
you don't want somebody trying to offer
you like let's do this for money as
opposed to putting it you have one sort
of pulling mouthpiece out in public
that's always a sign that they're
comfortable
the trains one throws a mouthpiece
dogs yeah no like for myself the only
time I've ever actually got in fights
was either when I was bullied or this
the second time they like literally for
the only time I'd ever fight myself or
fight anybody is uh playing sports like
I've advised playing basketball someone
undercut me I'd be the first one be like
dude you can take my legs out you know
like or play football so what you know
spirity in the knee or you know
something stupid but those are the only
times I'd actually get mad where I'm
like I'll fight you did you get pull
even your kid all the time you did
somebody fighters happen either a big
brother or somebody but who bullied you
just you know like I was always the kid
that just played sports and then there's
the older kids always just picked on you
what was their thing cuz you're a big
guy and you like you known to not be and
would be considered stereotypical
fighter shape and that your black belt
in jujitsu and the tremendous athlete so
was it was it was that that or was it
like your personality no I I think all
the way to like probably junior high and
then from high school then it switched
over there cuz then I just start playing
sports like sports in high school when
you're on the varsity team then
everybody just stays away from you when
you're the cool jock handle being
bullied
oh just no just easy I mean and just
walked away like I was never the person
that kind of confronted J you know I
unless I had yeah so do you see those
guys now and later like it's amazing
like people who [ __ ] with you and
you're a kid or who didn't treat you
properly and then they that you don't
they don't think you remember them but
you remember them I really don't
remember them because it's looking in
the past I'm always going forward you
are you know are you okay
I look person in a relationship right
harp on an argument I can't let it go
and I'm a resentful miserable guy if you
fight with your wife can you let it go
and even if she's wrong right [ __ ] it
and move forward and not obsess depends
on what she's wrong about if she's
really wrong about something then it's
something that's gonna be something
that's gonna mess up the relationship
for the future cuz it's gonna kinda like
you're you know like when you your kid
or you know anytime you're you're
learning something as long as it's
something that you can move forward with
like it has to be fixed if not it's
always gonna be the problem in the
future like it's one of those situations
like let's fix it or don't ever bring it
up again yeah I start something with you
with your talk about your wife and how
she likes she what she actually wants
you to have the mullet yeah no no she
she loves the hair like the first we
started as a joke and then but she you
know she she loves the Arabic
she doesn't have any hairs what she says
so she wants you to have all of it it's
fine somebody in the relationships got
to yeah but it's just interesting what
what else to what a woman can get you to
do like that's that's kind of amazing
like you know a woman woman like
something you keeping this is kind of
low I mean if I had like a sweet mullet
and I had the support of a woman saying
yeah you should keep it like I'd be on
cloud nine cuz it's cool to have a
mullet and then to have a girl to be
like yeah no that is cool cuz it's cool
for you to have a mullet but generally
there's not people around you being like
yeah that's a good look
well you got a girl who says it is a
good look that you're golden yeah that's
probably not something a lot of women
have said that works for you it's your
look I mean of course but I'm just in
general there's a lot of people in the
eighties used to say it all the time
that's a nice-looking mole right he's
right you know
somebody flavor speaking of the past Jim
actually has a game that he likes to
play with the guests and I thought
actually we played it with the list we'd
like your game yeah yeah yeah it's my it
was to our we wanted to know because
we're all big Donny and Marie fans as
most people are and we've been asking
people if they're more country or more
rock and roll so I would like your
answer actually do I should I mean yeah
you wanna play it sure sure we do a
formal playing game right I don't even
think of it and queued up we're still
sitting through the ad okay yeah we
should would you see to bring you guys
up to speed just to bring a portable
play the options just right yeah that's
generally fair enough yeah a song of
course that's where the options are just
the first two I mean you know how to
play the game free
[Music]
I thought I could have cured the Sun so
nicely that's like okay now who do we
who would like to play first um
bro I think you'd the obvious answer so
let's go that one Roy would you like
okay
all right which one are you hey you know
what I know it's a tough one that's why
you like to play again definitely a
tough one um um let's go six I mean he
goes so hard in that rock and run really
does a gut felt I really I really looked
up to him when I was a kid I was I'm 49
so I was [ __ ] eight years old on the
show came out I thought he was amazing I
thought it was cool but hindsight I'd
feel differently but let's not go way
off the rails here we're in the middle
of the game we sure are
right you have to choose soccer net well
I mean with with big you wanna do you
wanna have the options presented
[Laughter]
[Music]
inspiring rock and hey but I gotta tell
you I think I'm probably country cuz
this is my daily garb right look at me
go Troy that's a giant belt buckle now
you want to know something about this
belt book I do Jeremy Shockey and I
bought these but we we each bought our
own belt buckles not matching sure when
we were rookies and so I've had this
belt buckle since 2002 and you got your
teenager and we got with the Giants yeah
so I got it I got this when I saw the
Giants 2002 and I've won it almost every
day of my life there's this race it does
it bring back anything at this point or
is just your belt it's just my belt it's
just what it's it's my it's my belt
buckle you don't feel like they even own
a wedding ring when I got married yet I
still have this why did you not have
money for a ring uh
no I had money for it I just uh I'm not
a jewelry guy I don't like it at all and
I miss a big shiny belt because I hold
my pants up right
but like as far as as far as having like
jewelry and with a ring if you like I
cheated on my ex-wife and I'm a straight
douchebag for doing it and that's one of
them I'm actually extremely open about
it because I have so many people that
come up to me and be like hey man like
you know I talked about having like a
good boy cheetah and I'm like oh you
know I'm thinking about doing this I got
this girl on the side and blah blah my
response is do it if you want my opinion
don't do it because gonna feel like a
douche bag thing to do it you're gonna
have two separate lives and a lot of
people think like look I'm gonna get I'm
gonna get half the arguments and twice a
[ __ ] that's true for about the first
month and then all sudden it's flip
flops and you get half you get half the
putting in twice the arguments and it's
so much stress and it's not worth it so
like and so anyway so my point before I
got off yeah on that that bit there is
that it's if you're gonna cheat you're
gonna cheat when you have a ring on or
not so I never really felt like it like
having a ring was that relevant because
if I'm committed to my wife I was gonna
be good to her I just wasn't ready to be
married and I just made some bad
decision what were you doing for work
were you fighting over you or you still
play football um I was at the tail-end I
was in that transition part of my life
and I think that's probably one of the
biggest reasons why like why our
marriage didn't work is because I was
transitioning him from a couple
different things she was saying the same
and I think that I I didn't accept the I
I don't think I was mature enough to
understand like what she was going
through at the time by like having like
when I went on The Ultimate Fighter my
second son was just born he was two
months old my oldest son was three and a
half years old and she was left there
all alone like taking care of him then
all sudden I get off the Ultimate
Fighter and then like when he got the
showing you might have been in this way
too like it's kind of a good weird
transition because like there's no media
of any form like you we had we had a
45-minute drive each way to and from
practice so and you practice twice a day
so you're in the car for three hours a
day with no radio no no news no TV no
magazines of books no nothing so it's
like a real unique environment it's like
it's a living embodiment of Lord of the
Flies can you keep your phone's or no no
no no phone no media of any form so the
outside world nothing so like when I got
off my first questions are what's the
stock market and are we at war like
those are my good questions and like so
it was a weird transition for a little
bit so she's like at home waiting for me
to get home that's kind of relieve some
of the stress and I'm I get home and I'm
this weird tripped-out cat for a couple
of weeks and then I'll sudden I fight
Marcus and
Kimbo and everything changed and then
like when I say everything change like
when you beat him like I was sudden I
was in parties in LA where celebrities
knew my name and we're talking about my
fights like that was weird and I didn't
handle that transition very well and I
found a girl the big butt down in
Florida how did you get caught that's
what I'm fascinated is interesting
because Jim has also ended relationships
because his partners decided to
transition yes I have that's why I
started them but I've been an abominable
boyfriend yeah abomination of a
boyfriend I've gotten korchi how did you
get caught um she actually she heard me
but I like on the phone like it was it
was a situation in which there our we
had a huge fight she's Asian has a hell
of a temper and her mouth on her and she
said some things that I was like you
know what I don't want to be married to
that anymore I want to be out and this
is before I even ever cheated on her
whatever okay and I was you know I want
to be done with this I don't want to be
involved in this I'm not gonna have a go
on for the rest of my life and so I told
her one of the divorce and then three
weeks later I happened to be out in
Vegas and I'm next though I'd just be
Kimbo and I met a girl with a big button
a smile and then I carried that thing on
for four years I like carry on phone oh
you had like a whole little life Wow
never trust a big button a smile never
the girls the wisdom she's poison yeah
so you had a four year double life and
one new thought the other
no no mistress didn't know that the
mistress knew yeah I'm sorry yeah yeah
yeah the girlfriend knew about the wife
and I was like I'm going through a
divorce and blah blah and I just I
dragged my feet III really pissed up a
rope I did a horrible job managing my
life and that's right
horrible and that was it like 2010 like
2011 ish
probably 10 and then that went all the
way into like 2014 and I went like back
and forth cuz I was afraid I have three
kids so I was afraid I was gonna lose my
kids
and then like I wouldn't that would go
one way and I would go the other night
would flip-flop back and forth I made a
terrible series of decisions yeah and I
wanted to and enjoy your matter fighting
this this Friday night Mohegan Sun by
the way what are the reasons why
that fight is such a big deal is because
we're finally gonna see inside of a cage
the Battle of country versus rock for a
long time yeah and Donnie sounded
committed but I think Marie really kind
of started misogynist before and now I'm
totally with you Marie Osmond stink and
we know it stinks but yet there was a
part of me even I was actually giving it
up I was like you know what she really
has a great voice so I'm okay so you got
busted I'm always the moment you get
busted
like the moment I remember the moment I
got caught it's like well how did you
know
oh god it's done you know lingered for
so long it was never a point like that
but like she came in because she had
left and then I called up because I
guess she had left a couple messages
during the night and I called her in the
morning and apparently she had come back
in the house and been like hey I heard
what you know I heard you on the
telephone who are you talking to
and so the roughest and you know like
what that's like the beginning of like
the complete douchebaggery of like the
feeling of like jesus that guy she was
at home with my kids and I totally did
this thing that was such a douche like
and I felt that way like like it's one
of the very few times in my life I ever
felt like true remorse and guilt like
damn and I really screwed this thing up
yeah it's kind of when you really hear
your shitty actions made somebody else's
life miserable that sucks
but we're really good friends now and we
co-parent very well I even tweet about
it like we like we go to dinners
together we try to do stuff together and
she's really she's she's when she's
scoring she's a nasty manage amma but if
she tries only do the best for the kids
which I completely respect I understand
and if I in hindsight I would completely
change my actions and I wouldn't let
that happen you wouldn't do it yeah not
at all
I learned a tremendous amount from that
how did you meet your wife me I met her
in a weird situation cuz in Vegas uh you
know it's you know Sin City I met her at
a club oh you did yeah a night club
dance club no a nother an entertainment
establishment okay now are you
comfortable are you
confident like approaching someone like
that like a woman in a situation or they
have to approach you uh with this
situation like we're totally not Club
people like we don't go out like I just
can't happen to you know just kind of
because I we were both working and it we
just became friends you were bouncer or
yeah host haha you wear a suit did wear
see-through people out I didn't throw
anybody oh you know mattered for anybody
else no because I was a nice guy oh okay
so you'd you would just get to birth the
verbal combat you know like but
everybody else there's usually a bouncer
or a host or they're the ones that make
sure you hit the door on the way out
okay I was the guy going hey you sure
you want to do this
you sure trying to talk them out of it
right or or if you're the guy that had a
lot of money then I'd be like hey how
much money you can do being a complete
[ __ ] let me just see how much money
yeah if you have enough to make it worth
it then we could work it prepared me for
the UFC well you already taken rejected
by this point you were already training
that that's actually how I got it how I
got the job is just because I was good
at jujitsu oh so they figured you can
handle the situation exactly so you met
your wife through that and I guess she
liked you you a kind of protective and
you became friends and then you did yeah
she's like oh you're uh she was totally
thrown off when I was uh I was like yeah
I train people you know she thought it
was a personal trainer like a you know
like a CrossFit type of guy and I was
like and I'm like do I look like that
guy and she's like no and I'm like well
it didn't make any sense but I was like
no I trained jujitsu and then that's how
we got a kind of like hit it off and
then um and then just totally you know
just totally two different off it off
opposite sides of the tracks and then um
and then we've been together for 13
years now okay yeah you seem like you're
kind of a committed guy I've seen you in
interviews and stuff you seem fairly
committed and it's interesting looking
at the difference in what is you know
how you guys yeah you know I think the
difference is is since you're born in
Vegas kind of see everything
oh you raised it that's from born raised
so like you couldn't get all that that
out of your system by the time you're 21
once once once you're turned twenty-one
you could do everything you're like yeah
been there done that could you see the
casinos from where you are as a kid dude
I think the first time I ever gamble I
think was 15 1/2
all right yes you know it's like you
kind of like you know already like it's
just like if you're you know Midwest guy
you probably you start drinking when
you're 14 right you know either drinking
having sex like those are your like the
cool things to do while you're you know
and and then Vegas should pretty much
doing everything else so when you it's a
week I can't picture living in Vegas
it's just such a vacation spot or such a
place to go and work and get out of and
misbehave like I can't picture living
there and having a real life and then
not considering the casinos or what's on
the strip
ya know Vegas is definitely it's like I
think there's the the straight line of
the tracks where you kind of know what's
left what's right you know which way
you're gonna kind of go on and then I
play it up right on the tracks versus
jumping in one side or the other okay
let me ask you this now the first time
you were with a woman was it a girl you
met was it a girl that you were able to
go to the strip and say what do you mean
there's an availability there in Vegas
you know there's girls working girls
which I'm certainly partaking in when I
was in Vegas it's like when you're a
young man you state that is true there's
no state I haven't 17 18 years old and
you want to meet a girl you want to get
laid for the first time whatever it is
do you meet a girl high school or do you
go to the strip and you go the
old-fashioned way just you know you met
her at school right baby that's so much
easier now so much easier now people
people can just swipe and talk yet to
know each other and then power swiping
yeah I wonder if technology is gonna
absolutely slaughter marriage I wonder
if it's just going to be like it's an
institution of the of the past and now
with technology everybody's just
relationships of convenience you know
what is this it makes you realize how
many other people are out I think people
to things people talk to people and they
probably wouldn't have before because
you could just do it without on your
phone without moving but I also think
people go through whole relationships
and wind up never [ __ ] like I've gone
through entire relationships on text I
love you baby but I mean you just never
talk again and you've never met you man
you're never would've met her if it
wasn't for technology you wouldn't she
lives in Russia or something and you're
like well yeah if somebody that you're
never gonna meet physically but you go
through a whole emotional relationship
but then it Peters out why not stop
talking you just kind of you get bored
of each other yeah you you hit the you
get the dopamine drip sand you like
enough and you don't
[ __ ] so you know what the interesting
thing is is that back in the day right
like you know like every girl in your
town and the girls and surrounding towns
and now like you absolutely progressed
so like so now like that's why I think
like traditionally relationships now are
almost dead because everybody can go
online and see a girl that's 17 times
harder than the girl you just met in
real life and they act like it's so the
candy jar is always going to be more
full than what you're eating out of now
it's always gonna be so there's no way
for like for the integrity of an honest
relationship or community relationship
is gonna be compromised all the time
going forward and it's so much easier to
get caught so much easier because we
don't know where this stuff goes like
you know I mean like the iCloud I won't
go near iCloud I just won't do it
because it's a way to get caught so I
was on I was doing this podcast here
today and and and this thing this point
came up that every president from now on
from going forward it's gonna have a
dick pick out like you're gonna see
every president's [ __ ] going forward
there's because there's no way that
somebody in this day and age doesn't
have a dick pic app do you know I've
asked onstage cuz I've certainly sent a
whole bunch and I've asked on stage like
heaven has anybody they want and I know
some people are lying but there are
really people who don't do it I can't
get over that they haven't done it but
there are people that have not used that
technology for devious reasons no I
think it's uh it's kind of like are you
the criminal mastermind or are you just
the criminal that the henchmen that does
all the work so the criminal mastermind
will never have a dick thing right put
your dick on there it was but it said
that if you ever send your dick pic out
water market with the person's name who
you're sending it out so you know who
put your dick pic out and is such a
slick move I know that really I don't
have that many hours to watermark
different but that's actually a really
good move to send a little watermark I
don't put my face in it right I just
wouldn't put my face I wouldn't care if
you got anyone who cares but I don't I
don't do a full body right you know
that's that's a ramjet who it is look
I'm guess there's always some dead
giveaway or if you're a politician
they're almost afraid to lie too much
because they they know that that's the
ruin or it's not their crime is to cover
up what was it was it Johnny
yeah it really was a good name and the
creepiest dick photos my office chest
out in the congressional members of the
gym you're not only do have your face in
the dick pic you have your face and your
kids face yeah gimme your dick pic oh
that was wonder where to weigh underwear
and he had the kid on the man what are
you doing it was just bad timing of code
what it was bent
me me me need to take the photo with the
kid that was just I mean I think there
was there's there's more to I think you
think I want to jail yeah yeah he's in
jail I think he's in jail how much time
did he get for talking to the 15 year
old 23 months or something I thinks I'm
like a little bit less than ten years he
mayor in New York people loved he was
even even after he got busted Anthony we
get busted he comes back and then people
like you know what we like this guy he
was an advocate for the people would
have forgiven him texting he couldn't
stop buddy stop man you know the drug
but he's real do it the way I can figure
it's like it's like having menthol
injected into your head and your upper
chest it's this weird constant drip
every time the phone rings and you get
it and you look and it's another dirty
message he's gonna get out of jail he's
gonna be like I'm reformed come on but
he's gonna go right back into public
life he's gonna run for office again and
in the middle of him running for office
more dick pics he's gonna keep American
political situation right now is got to
be the most fascinating it's ever been
and recorded this incredibly since it's
every day there's something crazy red
blue left right center
ultra hard one way or the other just the
madness is going on crazy cuz everybody
can weigh in immediately now and we're
just not handling it well
no like you know we everyone can just
say whatever they think in that second
and we all have to hear and no one has
there's no button where you go I'll say
this in 10 minutes and you're not
talking about a dopamine drip people get
that dopamine drip to outrage to rally
against something and when they realize
like okay what's happening today oh this
person did this let's get everybody
let's hashtag this let's get everybody
in trouble like let okay what's my cause
tomorrow what's Mike you know what
what's amazing is that that was
the guy yeah like one of the presidents
of Facebook or like upper execs of
Facebook were like dude we knew that
we're ruining the world when we started
this unlike like that we knew the
repercussions and most likely what they
were going to be and it's kind of come
to fruition from the entire thing and
it's they're absolutely right there's no
way the world could process without
social information anymore yeah we'll
eventually handle it but I think our
generation I mean it's kind of like
we're the first ones to remember life
without do you remember life without
phones and without constant technical we
remember life before and we have it
younger people I handle it better
because they're used to just nothing but
that do you have kids
I have no kids no okay do you practice
any form of restraint like it at 10
o'clock at night I put my phone down and
put it on Do Not Disturb
or I turn my phone off and you turn it
on in the morning like oh you're you are
you hands off technology at certain
points or in the day when they get bored
and stop responding ah not regularly I
mean there will be moments that I go
like okay let me or you know I'll forget
I've done things where I'll forget my
phone at home and I'll realize in the
driveway and I'll go [ __ ] it and just
keep driving you know I mean so I'll do
that or like I'll take a moment and go
like let me let me put my phone away for
a few hours but not like a regular okay
10 o'clock that's my time to get to get
rid of it i chat with my kids I try to
do that with my kids 1297 does the
seven-year-old have a phone no none of
my kids have a phone I only have one
television in my house and there's no
games no iPads there's nothing
whoa nothing which isn't the
twelve-year-old like and I guess I don't
know I have an eleven month old so you
know I don't know this yeah thanks man
quit at twelve isn't he like getting to
the place where like all of his friends
have yes it has got to be difficult um
kind of sorta but he's a reader he's a
bookworm man like he just likes also
like he'll sit like if we're all sitting
around at nighttime like watching TV
together he'll pull up a book and he'll
sit in the room and just read a book
while the TV's on that's like the best
case scenario it's wasn't it but I feel
like we fight our asses off to not like
my ex-wife only has one that one TV and
house so like it's but my middle one
Jonah
live when he's about to be nine actually
he'll he's got a little hustle he'll run
over to the neighbor's house and go play
the
over there so like we're hit to the game
but like you know as long as you're
around other kids stay off your phone
then so they don't see you yeah that's
that's my compromise with them sometimes
like I do it but like with work and with
people coming in or with whatever else I
have to kind of respond to it yeah for
the most part no I do my thumb around
them or get out of it yeah okay we also
have to promote we have to leave the
rapper to five minutes we hit we just
writing to you guys the Bellator
heavyweight world Grand Prix tournament
it's at Bellator 194 and it's this
Friday nine o'clock on paramount Network
and the action is the Spike TV right you
don't have the Paramount network you
probably do have the Paramount that is
going to be this Friday at nine o'clock
and it's live from the Mohegan Sun are
the tickets available to go up and see
it or is it sold out do you don't know
it's sold out it should totally be sold
on I imagine it would be but if not
check it sometimes casinos hold tickets
for high rollers and they wind up
selling them late so you probably can
get casino tickets for those of you guys
that are in the fanbase that are
listening that are worried about combat
athletes taking steroids Roy and I were
both drug tested randomly we had we
fight in Connecticut we had to fly to LA
for a press conference for them the
first leg of the Grand Prix where
randomly drug tested by that Athletic
Commission of Connecticut and despite
both of our sexy physiques
we passed Wow random drug test we both
passed the rest of the field everybody
[Laughter]
these two chewed-up bubble gum stacks
and lets them do what they do well you
fight and I think your last fight was uh
was fatal and you beat him in the first
round I was it was a TKO or knockout her
yeah with fighting him the legendary
name that comes with that was it what
you thought it was gonna be um he's a
little older now too he's been around
for a while
or was it not what you thought he's
gonna be um it was uh the media
attention was it was substantial uh you
know what really sucked about about
fighting paid or like the lead-up into
it and then I had the kidney stones I
had to lead up to it again and then
because I was supposed to fight
phaidor in February of seventeen and I
had a kidney stone that that week of the
fight so I had to get cancelled and so
and then we had to redo the whole thing
over again and I fought him finally in
June
and then after I beat him but the whole
time in both lead-ups and afterwards I
got so many death threats to my my
children myself that they're gonna rape
my daughter like oh my god from from all
these Russians and it was incessant dude
it was so many so like that was like I
knew that that's like kind of a good
different world you know and now I would
get like hey look and like like man you
[ __ ] you are you beat like our and it
was like in their broken English of how
they could possibly do it and then I
tried to do it in English yeah and it
was like he's a complete national
treasure to us so [ __ ] you and your
entire family we're gonna rape your
daughter like like craziness like wow
that is a totally different so that was
my experience like it wasn't like like
oh my god it's a door it was like the
fan base and the reaction to was just
mad I wonder if we're doing about the
same thing or Dan Henderson other guys
that beaten him I wonder if this super
new bad to get worse I mean he was the
first person to do it that's right I
mean so that really that had to get
bananas after that well he had won
Worcester a but I think it was like a
disqualification or something it wasn't
I don't think was a doctor stoppage
faders first one yeah okay yeah so he
didn't know in his eyes he was still
kind of like 30 and 1 or somebody was
undefeated yeah yeah I guess we're doing
got a whole bunch of hates weird how
people like two guys are fighting what
the [ __ ] do you expect him to do not one
of them is gonna win yeah yeah yeah he
would gladly have knocked you out I mean
what are they to do yeah I don't know it
was it was a trip man it was wow it was
like it was really difficult cuz I'm
very proud of my family I'm like we have
a good you know nuclear work and I'd
like to see him stuff like that at first
it really upset me and then I was you
know what doing Russia's gonna rush yeah
man you there's nothing you can do about
it do you does it bother you too because
like we were talking before the show
even by people that will say things
they're anonymous that's just annoying
but as guys who handle things
differently does it bother you there's
some people know like my very first um
like spirits where somebody fanbase when
they wanted to kill me was uh when I
fight Kimber oh yeah they I got a
fanbase that like I kill you you know
though might kill my family the whole
nine years and then I'm going but it was
tape delayed by six months
don't wanna kill him like really thought
it happened last week they're like oh
I'm gonna kill you but the best thing
about that is my um my urban demographic
went way up it's a right because people
didn't know you want up liking it was
just jealous rules
well UK and you guys fought by the way
and you want to know for the first round
was the first round TKO and and how does
that make you feel fighting to somebody
who's beaten you have you had rematch
with guys who beat you before no I've
never had a rematch supposed to be my
first one but me too yeah well this is
um you know it's kind of unique because
it was my it was my sixth fight ever
right now this is me making excuses it
was my sixth fight ever bah blah blah
whatever whatever but he beat me
legitimately first guy to ever knock me
down hit me on the punch I didn't see
and he jumped on top of in capitalized
so you know I feel that I'm a very I've
grown a lot
that was my sixth fight ever I think it
was his 20 for the 25th so there was a
lot of education that I still had to get
on the way up right and then I think
I've gotten that education I think I've
learned it I think I've learned a lot a
lot about how I fight and my strength
misses are I think I had the tools to
win before I think it was like like
impatience I think I had a lot of things
going on my life I got like you know I
left cattle bag I was like all that
cheating the divorce all the madness had
all that stuff going on in my life at a
time and I wasn't as focused as I showed
him in I think my life's a much much
cleaner now and I've done a really good
job as far as managing that so I think I
obviously I think it'll be a different
result what you like the first time you
get knocked down it was it was I I I
didn't I didn't see it coming so I hit
the ground it's like what the hell am i
doing on the ground like that's so odd
and all set he was on top of me and then
like I didn't I didn't know how to
handle that situation I never practice
that situation and so I and I lost my
and that was you know kudos Roy he knew
exactly what to do and how to capitalize
on it how it was perfect how much does
it suck when you go why am I on the
floor and then you're looking to see him
he'll [ __ ] so you don't you don't
actually know it in the moment until
you're done yeah
like when I got me like a hit with fader
when we both dropped like that's only I
think the third time in my career have
been dropped and I was like what it
looks like all [ __ ] but I better knock
him out now like if he hit me or
something I dropped me I didn't see it I
better I've already learned that
experience once I better capitalize on
this one